hi guys a moneyed one from simply learn
and today I will be giving you a
tutorial on one of the most talked about
topics in the world of technology and
that is machine learning I'm sure that
if you are watching this video you must
have heard about machine learning
somewhere or the other and yes it is
quite an intriguing topic this video
will act as a supplement for the ones
who know the basics of machine learning
and are aware of where it is being used
and how it is being used for the ones
who are completely new to this you don't
have to worry we will be brushing up the
basics as well so to start off with
let's have a look at the agenda first we
look into our life without machine
learning then we will move into a life
with machine learning then we'll try to
understand what is machine learning
actually then we look into the types of
machine learning we'll talk about the
right machine learning solutions then
we'll move into the different algorithms
that machine learning has finally we'll
do a use case wherein we'll be
predicting the price of a house using
linear regression let's talk about our
life without machine learning for
someone who doesn't know anything about
machine learning or artificial
intelligence he or she might think that
it is only being used in robots or
machines and stuff which is actually
true as portrayed by most of the sci-fi
movies nowadays but you wouldn't believe
how much more machine learning is giving
us how much of it we are using in our
daily lives let's say you need
information on any random topic say a
computer the first place you would check
would definitely be Google right it
would collect all the information on the
word you search for and present it to
you according to relevance if there was
no Google you would have to do it in a
very hard way that is by going through
tens or hundreds of books and articles
even after which you won't find the
answer if we go back four to five years
facial recognition would be a thing only
showed in movies like Mission Impossible
or terminator or any of the sci-fi
movies you pick but machine learning has
made it possible for Facebook and
Instagram to use this feature for your
benefits you don't have to go through
the trouble of tagging every single
person present in a picture that you
have posted face
will automatically recognize the people
in the photo and tag them for you that
saves a lot of time for you doesn't it
also Siri Cortana iris all of them would
not be there to help you if there was no
machine learning now that we know life
would be a lot more difficult without
machine learning let's look into the
things that are run by machine learning
and we are using them on our daily basis
let's enter the world of gaming DS foes
and Xboxes have introduced virtual
reality glasses which brings a whole new
level of detail into gaming every time
your head moves in real world it
replicates the movement in the virtual
world providing an excellent gaming
experience then there is gesture control
gaming where in machine learning tracks
your body movement and makes a
corresponding movement in the game
finally in the game FIFA your opera
intends to adapt based on the kind of
strategy or gameplay you follow that is
again done by machine learning
I'm sure you must have shopped a lot
from Amazon so let's look into some of
the places Amazon makes use a machine
learning let's say you buy a formal
t-shirt on Amazon now as you buy it it
suggests you formal shoes ties Blazers
and Apparel's that go with what you have
bought that's the recommendation system
powered by machine learning again the
price on every product that you see on
Amazon is varying every moment based on
demand that's being done by machine
learning algorithms then comes customer
segmentation customer segmentation is
one of the most crucial thing for all
the e-commerce platforms machine
learning helps them differentiate
between customers based on what they buy
how frequent are they and their reviews
this helps the companies to make sure
that their customers are taken care of
and the needs are being fulfilled now
let's talk about an app that you use on
a daily basis to reach office on time
yes it's uber caps once you have
traveled with uber you must have noticed
s-- that it suggests you the places you
might want to go based on your previous
journeys when you're taking a share how
does the app make sure that the cab you
get is traveled by the same route you
want to travel in there are so many
factors like the distance the traffic
the ratings all of it is taken care of
by machine learning for the past five
minutes we have been talking about how
machine learning is improving our lives
where all it is being used are you
probably said machine learning a hundred
times already I think it's about time
that I tell you what machine learning
actually is let's take an ordinary
system that you currently are using it
can't do much except from the basic
operations that you already know about
now let's add artificial intelligence or
for a layman's point of view let's give
the same machine the power to think on
its own that is what machine learning
basically is it's an application of
artificial intelligence that provides
systems the ability to learn on their
own and improve from experience without
being programmed externally so if your
computer had machine learning maybe able
to play the difficult parts of a game
for you or probably solve a complicated
mathematical equation for you that could
be really helpful
let's dive in a little deeper and see
how machine learning works let's say you
provide a system with the input data
that carries the photos of various kinds
of fruits now you won the system to
figure out what are the different fruits
and grouped them accordingly so what the
system does it analyzes the input data
then it tries to find patterns patterns
like shapes size and color based on
these patterns the system will try to
predict the different types of fruit and
segregate them finally it keeps track of
all such decisions it took in the
process to make sure it's learning the
next time you ask the same system to
predict and segregate the different
types of fruits it won't have to go
through the entire process again
that's how machine learning works now
let's look into the types of machine
learning machine learning is primarily
of three types first one is supervised
machine learning as the name suggests
you have to supervise the machine
learning while you train it to work on
its own it requires label training data
next up is unsupervised learning wherein
there will be training data but it won't
be labeled finally there is
reinforcement learning wherein the
system learns on its own let's talk
about all these types in details let's
try to understand how supervised
learning works look at the pictures very
very carefully the monitor depicts the
model or the system that we are going to
train this is how the training is done
we provide a data set that contains
pictures of a kind of a fruit say an
apple then we provide another data set
which lets the model know that these
pictures were that of a fruit called
Apple this ends the training phase now
what we will do is we provide a new set
of data which only contains pictures of
Apple now here comes the fun part
the system can actually tell you what
fruit it is and it will remember this
and apply this knowledge in future as
well that's how supervised learning
works you are training the model to do a
certain kind of an operation on its own
this kind of a model is generally used
in to filtering spam mails from your
email accounts as well yes surprised
aren't you so let's move on to one
supervised
learning now let's say we have a data
set which is cluttered in this case we
have a collection of pictures of
different fruits we feed this data to
the model and the model analyzes the
data to figure out patterns in it in the
end it categorizes the photos into three
types as you can see in the image based
on their similarities so you provide the
data to the system and let the system do
the rest of the work
simple isn't it this kind of a model is
used by Flipkart to figure out the
products that are well suited for you
honestly speaking this is my favorite
type of machine learning out of all the
three and this type has been widely
shown in most of the sci-fi movies
lately let's find out how it works
imagine a newborn baby you put a burning
candle in front of the baby the baby
does not know that if it touches the
flame its fingers might get burned so it
does that anyway and gets hurt
the next time you put that candle in
front of the baby
it will remember what happened the last
time and would not repeat what it did
that's exactly how reinforcement
learning works we provide the machine
with the data set wherein we ask it to
identify a particular kind of a fruit in
this case an apple so what it does as a
response it tells us that it's a mango
but as we all know it's a completely
wrong answer so as a feedback we tell
the system that it's wrong it's not a
mango it's an apple what it does it
learns from the feedback and keeps that
in mind when the next time when we ask a
same question it gives us the right
answer it is able to tell us that it's
actually an apple that is a reinforced
response so that's how reinforcement
learning works it learns from his
mistakes and experiences this model is
used in games like Prince of Persia or
assassin's creed or FIFA but in the
level of difficulty increases as you get
better with the games just to make it
more clear for you let's look at a
comparison between supervised and
unsupervised learning firstly the data
involved in case of supervised learning
is labeled as we mentioned in the
examples previously we provide the
system with a photo of an apple and let
the system know that this is actually an
apple that is called label data so the
system learns from the label data and
make
future predictions now unsupervised
learning does not require any kind of
label data because it's work is to look
for patterns in the input data and
organize it the next point is that you
get a feedback in case of supervised
learning that is once you get the output
the system tends to remember that and
uses it for the next operation that does
not happen for unsupervised learning and
the last point is that supervised
learning is mostly used to predict data
whereas unsupervised learning is used to
find out hidden patterns or structures
in data I think this would have made a
lot of things clearer for you regarding
supervised and unsupervised learning now
let's talk about a question that
everyone needs to answer before building
a machine learning model what kind of a
machine learning solution should we use
yes you should be very careful with
selecting the right kind of solution for
your model because if you don't you
might end up losing a lot of time energy
and processing cost I won't be naming
the actual solutions because you guys
aren't familiar with them yet so we will
be looking at it based on supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
so let's look into the factors that
might help us select the right kind of
machine learning solution first factor
is the problem statement describes the
kind of model you will be building or as
the name suggests it tells you what the
problem is for example let's say the
problem is to predict the future stock
market prices so for anyone who is new
to machine learning would have trouble
figuring out the right solution but with
time and practice you will understand
that for a problem statement like this
solution based on supervised learning
would work the best for obvious reasons
then comes the size quality and nature
of the data if the data is cluttered you
go for unsupervised the data is very
large and categorical we normally go for
supervised learning solutions finally we
choose the solution based on the
complexity as for the problem statement
wherein we predict the stock market
prices it can also be solved by using
reinforcement learning but that would be
very very difficult and time-consuming
and like supervised learning
algorithms are not types of machine
learning in the most simplest language
they are methods of solving a particular
problem so the first kind of method is
classification which falls under
supervised learning classification is
used when the output you are looking for
is a yes or a no or in the form a or b
or true or false
like if a shopkeeper wants to predict if
a particular customer will come back to
his shop or not he will use a
classification algorithm the algorithms
that fall on the classification are
decision tree
night base random forest logistic
regression and K&M the next kind is
regression this kind of a method is used
when the predicted data is numerical in
nature like if the shopkeeper wants to
predict the price of a product based on
its demand it would go for regression
the last method is clustering clustering
is a kind of unsupervised learning Union
it is used when the data needs to be
organized most of the recommendation
system used by Flipkart
Amazon etc make use of clustering
another major application of it is in
search engines the search engines study
your old search history to figure out
your preferences and provide you the
best search results one of the
algorithms that fall under clustering is
kami
now that we know the various algorithms
let's look into four key algorithms that
are used widely we will understand them
with very simple examples
the four algorithms that we will try to
understand k-nearest neighbor linear
regression decision tree and knife base
let's start with our first machine
learning solution k nearest neighbor
clay nearest neighbor is again a kind of
a classification algorithm as you can
see on the screen the similar data
points form clusters the blue one the
red one and the green one there are
three different clusters now if we get a
new and unknown data point it is
classified based on the cluster closest
to it or the most similar to it k in KN
n is the number of nearest neighboring
data points we wish to compare the
unknown data with let's make it clear
with an example let's say we have three
clusters in a cost to durability graph
first cluster is of footballs the second
one is of tennis balls and the third one
is of basketballs from the graph we can
say that the cost of footballs is high
and the durability is less the cost of
tennis balls is very less but the
durability is high and the cost of
basketballs is as high as the durability
now let's say we have an unknown data
point we have a black spot which can be
one kind of the balls but we don't know
what kind it is so what we will do will
try to classify this using K n n so if
we take K is equal to five we draw a
circle keeping the unknown data point in
the center and we make sure that we have
five balls inside that circle in this
case we have a football a basketball and
three tennis balls now since we have the
highest number of tennis persons as a
circle the classified ball would be a
tennis ball so that's how K nearest
neighbor classification is done linear
regression is again a type of supervised
learning algorithm this algorithm is
used to establish linear relationship
between variables one of which would be
dependent and the other one would be
independent
like if we want to predict the weight of
a person based on his height weight
would be the dependent variable and
height would be independent let's have a
look at it through an example
let's say we have a graph here showing a
relationship between height and weight
of a person let's put the y-axis as H
and the x-axis as weight
so the green dots are the various data
points these green dots are the data
points and D is the mean squared error
that is the perpendicular distances from
the line to the data points are the
error values this error tells us how
much the predicted values vary from the
original value
let's ignore this blue line for a while
so let's say if this is a regression
line you can see the distance from all
the data points from this line is very
high
so if we take this line as a regression
line the error in the prediction will be
too high so in this case the model will
not be able to give us a good prediction
let's say we draw another regression
line like this even in this case you can
see that the perpendicular distance of
the data points from the line is very
high so the error value will still come
as high as the last one so this model
will also not be able to give us a good
prediction so what to do so finally we
draw a line which is this blue line so
here we can see that the distance of the
data points from the line is very less
relative to the other two lines we drew
so the value of d for this line will be
very less so in this case if we take any
value on the x-axis the corresponding
value on the y-axis will be our
prediction and given the fact that the D
is very low our prediction should be
good also
this is how regression works we draw a
line a regression line that is in such a
way that the value of D is the least
eventually giving us good predictions
this algorithm that is decision tree is
a kind of an algorithm you can very
strongly relate to it uses a kind of a
branching method to realize the problem
and make decisions based on the
conditions let's take this graph as an
example imagine yourself sitting at home
getting bored you feel like going for a
swim what you do is you check if it's
sunny outside so that's your first
condition if the answer to that
condition is yes you go for a swim if
it's not sunny in the next question you
would ask yourself is if it's raining
outside so that's condition number two
if it's actually raining you cancel the
plan and stay indoors if it's not
raining then you would probably go
outside and have a walk so that's the
final node that's how decision tree
algorithm works you probably use this
every day it realizes a problem and then
takes the decisions based on the answers
to every conditions
nine bits algorithm is mostly used in
cases where a prediction needs to be
done on a very large data set it makes
use of conditional probability
conditional probability is the
probability of an event say a happening
given that another even B has already
happened
this algorithm is most commonly used in
filtering spam mails in your email
account let's say you receive a mail the
model goes through your own spam mill
records then it uses space theorem to
predict if the present mail is a spam
mail or not so PC of a is the
probability of even see occurring when a
has already occurred P a of C is the
probability of given a occurring when C
has already occurred and BC is the
probability of event C occurring and P a
is a probability of event a operating
let's try to understand I base with a
better example
Nighy base can be used to determine on
which days to play cricket
based on the probabilities of a taping
rainy windy or sunny the model tells us
if a match is possible if we consider
all the weather conditions to be even a
for us and the probability of them as
being possible event C so the model
applies the probabilities of event a and
C into the base theorem and predicts if
a game of cricket is possible on a
particular day or not in this case if
the probability of C of a is more than
0.5 we can be able to play a game of
cricket if it's less than 0.5 we won't
be able to do that that's how nine based
algorithm works now we have reached the
most important part of our video the use
case where n will be predicting the
price of a house using machine learning
look at this guy he seems a bit for it
doesn't he
let's figure out what the problem here
is so he's planning on selling his house
in a few months but he's unable to
decide what price he should sell it for
so let's help him predict the price of
his house using machine learning so our
problem statement is to predict the
price of a house using machine learning
that
be implemented on Python now the first
job at hand is to figure out which
algorithm to use it we will be using
linear regression for this problem as I
mentioned before linear regression is a
kind of supervised learning let's have a
look at the reason why we are choosing
linear regression over all the other
algorithms so the first reason here is
the output is quantitative in nature and
directly proportional to the variables
so I have mentioned this before many
many times that if the prediction is
quantitative in nature linear regression
is the best choice the next reason is
low computation cost what does it mean
if you use an algorithm that involves a
lot of equation solving and stuff you'll
need a very powerful system so that will
cost you more but not in the case of
linear regression because it is a very
simple algorithm and it can be done in
any normal system finally linear
regression is easy to understand as I
mentioned before let's have a look at
the various features in the data set the
first feature is the lower status of
population in that area then comes the
mean price of all the houses in their
area then the building age the tax rate
the average number of rooms in every
houses the distance to five Boston
employments accessibility to highways
and finally the per capita crime rate so
these all are the factors that we'll be
taking into consideration to predict the
price of a house let's move ahead so
let's quickly try to understand how
linear regression works so this is your
model the computer here and you provide
the training data all the values for the
different features you provide the
system so that it can learn from it as
you can see it is trying to study the
training data it learns from it and then
you give it the test data you give it
some values that it needs to predict the
from the training data that it learned
it will be able to predict the price of
the house that's how the entire model
works it's simple right now that we
understand what we are supposed to do
let's implement the entire model on
Python we will be using Jupiter notebook
to run the code it's because it will be
easier for you to understand and I'll be
able to explain every line of it to you
properly will be used
scikit-learn to load all the data and
libraries Saeki learn is a liability
specially dedicated to machine learning
in case you are programming on python so
let's start off by importing the
required libraries for the model so
let's import the various libraries from
scikit-learn firstly comes up numpy
numpy is a support for large arrays and
matrices that we are going to use in
this use case then comes pandas pandas
is a package that makes working with
relational data easier then from the
regression model that we are going to
use to check the accuracy of the model
we import train tests split from scaler
and dot cross-validation import train
test split
so that's it all the important libraries
have been imported let's move on now to
run the cell we press Shift + Enter
so that's it the cell is running
properly now from scikit-learn again we
load the data set and load that the
chorus from s Kalyan dot datasets
import load Boston
slyness Postum equal to load
so it makes it easier for us to load the
entire data set if you want so again
pressing shift and enter around the
cells no errors so now we'll try to have
a look at the data set posture so as you
can see
the entire data set is available in
front of us this is the entire data set
this are the values of all the features
that we have these are the names of the
features that we talked about before
and these are the target values with
this value we will compare the
predictions that we have
so now we'll divide the data into two
different data frames this is how we
create a data P D F X this is one of the
data frame equal to P D so here's where
the pandas liability come into work
Boston the data columns equal to Boston
our features feature names so the next
data frame would be the f y2 frame
Boston dot target so in this data frame
all the target values will be loaded so
that's it we run the cell to that's
running fine now let's try to describe
the data that is our DF x
not described now you can see that this
table provides us with the count of
every features the mean value for every
feature and the standard deviation so
all this data can be useful but not in
this case so let's not waste time here
so next comes an important part here we
will apply regression now so the code is
re G equal to linear model not linear
regression so that's why we loaded this
library in the beginning we press Shift
+ Enter
now we split our data into train and
test data to validate the model as we go
ahead I will show you how to do it as
well the core is X train comma X test
common y train my test equal to train
dust split the FX comedy of Y this size
that size is equal to 0.2 so that means
20% of the data is test in the remaining
is train - so random state is needed
when we are to run and validate our
model multiple times so in this case we
put it is equal to 4 so now what we do
is we fit the data set into the
regression function the code is re g dot
fit x string y train Shipton enter and
now as we can see that our data set is
fit into the function that we call
before line 14 you can see that
so next let's check the coefficient so
the code is re G dot F so these are the
weights and these are optimal
so let me tell you what coefficient
actually is so the coefficients give us
an idea of how much the dependent
variable will increase if the
independent variable value increases by
one if you take the equation of a line
let's say the regression line that is YX
equal to MX plus C so C is the constant
and M is the coefficient in this case
very simple okay now we will predict the
prices so a will be the predicted price
so a equal to re Qi dot predict X test
so we will be predicting the prices
according to arrays okay so a in
brackets will specify the area number so
in this case we give three as we press
ENTER we get array equal to 18 point 15
so for array three we are getting 18
point one so if we check on the test
data what is the value for array number
three this is error number 0 this is 1 2
3 4 array 3 the test data is 19.3
and we are getting 18.1 so that's the
prediction so you can see that the
predicted value and the original value
don't very much the predictions are
pretty good
so now let's test for array number five
so in the test table there is 0 1 2 3 4
5 so in the test the value for the fifth
array is twenty four point five and we
are getting twenty five point four so
the prediction is still pretty good so
our model is functioning pretty well now
let's try and find the error so the code
will be n P dot mean and prat it a - why
test so a is the predicted value and why
test is the test value this gives us the
error now if we square this value we get
the mean squared error
to shift and enter
so the error value is 25 so that's a
mean square error so we have
successfully created a linear regression
model now the error value that we got is
25 which is good enough as you have seen
in the predictions it can be made better
by manipulating the data as well
lesser the mean squared error better the
predictions so let me go through the
entire process once more for your
convenience firstly we'll be importing
the various liabilities from
scikit-learn then we load the Boston
data set from scikit-learn again
then we transfer the data into two
different data frames so if we describe
the Boston data set we get a table like
this wherein we get the count mean value
and standard deviation for every feature
then we change the regression model next
up we split the data into test and train
we're in the test size is 0.2 and the
random state is equal to 4 then we fit
the data into the regression model after
that we calculate the coefficients and
the value of the coefficients you can
see on the screen then we try to predict
the prices so for array number 2 we get
a value 17.5 and for the same array on
the test data
it is 17.4 so the difference between the
predicted data and the original data is
very less a model was functioning pretty
well for Aaron number 3 we get 18 point
1 and on the test data it is nineteen
point three so finally we calculate the
mean square error which came out to be
25 point four which is quite good for
our model to summarize the entire video
let's look at a few important things we
talked about firstly we learned how
machine learning is affecting our
day-to-day lives with Facebook Flipkart
uber etc and we understood what machine
learning actually is then we talked
about three types of machine learning
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement we did a comparison
between supervised and unsupervised
learning wherein we learned that
supervised learning involves label data
and in case of unsupervised learning
there is non label data in here
supervise there is direct feedback and
gets unsupervised there is no feedback
finally supervised learning is used to
predict output an unsupervised learning
is used to find hidden structure in data
then we try to understand the four
widely used machine learning algorithms
that are K nearest neighbor linear
regression decision trees knife base
then we learn when to use classification
algorithms regression algorithms and
clustering algorithms finally we did a
use case wherein we predicted the price
of a house with a mean square error
value of twenty five point four which
turned out to be pretty fine so that
brings us to the end of the video I hope
you guys understood the concepts put
your doubts and feedback in the comments
below and stay tuned for more videos hi
there if you liked this video subscribe
to the simple learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos
turner up and get certified click here